hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play dark ocean I
actually have absolutely no idea what
this is about because I don't even
remember downloading this I just looked
at my folder of games that I said that I
needed to play and it was like there I
don't remember how I don't remember why
I didn't even know what this is about
oiled enemy non-oil denim what do they
need to be oiled what is going on in
this game flare gun
okay what oh oh I don't I seriously do
not remember ever downloading this game
it just appeared on my harddrive so I
guess it's destiny telling me I need to
play this I'll you remember downloading
anything that even relates to lighting
enemies on fire oiled as they may be in
the darkest of moments of life is when
our true value is revealed hmm my name
is Liz hi losing engineer and this is
the ship I've designed nice ship tonight
an unknown disease has taken over the
ship and its passengers I don't know if
I'm the only survivor probably not I
think I'm alone oh hello I look familiar
rag me to the dark ocean no not the dark
ocean
okay that makes sense oh it's a loading
screen okay I have no idea what was
going on for a second there hi what dot
okay there we go
sorry mysterious stuff happening off
screen you don't need to know about you
don't you didn't know okay oh whoa hey
whoa extreme third-person it's like I'm
sitting right on her shoulder and oh
that way there and then there we go haha
I do not remember ever seeing a
screenshot about this oh nice hat oh hey
don't turn off the lights I need those
ha oh hello boom why do I only have a
flare gun what what okay yeah I got it I
got how do I know when there's oil on
the ground
oh is that oil on the ground the clearly
marked white lines huh
who is this I don't even know how old
this game is I don't know where alright
my mind is going the floor is falling
down I can't go to the casino through
the main entrance I'll have to go
through the pool first I need to go to
the elevator at the far end of the hall
to get there I'm trying to be her Liz
cuz I can't you know show objectives and
map I mean it seems like it's well made
I mean I don't know I didn't see a game
studio at all I don't even know what
engine this is made on it seems like
something from you know the old era of
games like PlayStation 2 quality
graphics here but you know I I'm I'm
just utterly confused more than anything
okay something bout an elevator boop
boop boop boop boop
either way it wasn't an installer it was
just a self run game which reminded me
of what the Unity engine does but you
know I'm not uh once again I'm speaking
outside of my expertise is this I can't
go in there I'm really bloodied up you
know should not be worried about me
getting infected can't jump
I guess not I'm too tough for that right
Liz yeah that's right I'll take half
body Python drew how do tough no one's
gonna stop me
ah you're gonna stop a good eye your
mouth perfect okay enough of this stupid
voice good Sarah how's her was that oh
the door closed why was that such a
serious door opening happening covered
some health I thought I was at full
health well I'm a little bloodied up but
oh okay radio I was like well what's on
a demon scape is this I need to get
downstairs can I just jump down here
yeah good oh god it's too hot ahh
whoa nice vertical okay I'm guessing
these are pools of oh no you're not
oiled and I got a run through the oil
and then not you [ __ ] wha
all right Mitch Mitch Oh looks like that
my flare gun has a clip of four that's
really handy for when I need rapid fire
flares what is going on ooh a camera huh
damn yeah
what nothing better than a camera pair
don't make me take a picture of you how
do I use it I didn't see was there a
button that I needed to press for the
camera what that what did I just do cue
sneaky sneak no one was expecting now I
crouched down a few inches
I am totally invisible no one will
suspect the crouching woman in biker
shorts Oh No
huh what are those vials or something
Liuzza's ha hope I busted it up whatever
it was about to flare boxing some fuel
oh okay em the door's locked
I'll have to find the key for at first
what oh oh oh did not expect that okay
up top da da
how do I get the camera out oh that's
how I right-click the monster drop
something that looks like a key well
well isn't that handy where is it oh did
I already get it okay
that sure was handy I like wait a minute
I could have I jumped off of that first
floor balcony totally parkour dit oh hey
uh hi there how about you uh come at me
bro hey hey hey come at me
hahaha you start you can kick me through
the fire oh you Boosh
run run lady lady run oh no bro light
him on fire
oh he's not lighting on fire boy let's
stop it stop aiming and go and then
flossing with your boobs
oh he's blinded by de oh he's on fire
died why isn't he dying you're on fire
bro good deer yeah about time aho he
can't hurt me I'm a strong independent
woman who don't need no man I mean I'm a
strong independent woman who don't need
no man okay there we go that's how I
thought call button is broken the
elevator won't come down well yell at it
geez
okay I need to get down to the swimming
pool that was right that was the
original objective I remember that I
don't know how big this game is but it
must be at least a little substantial
that's gonna pop out there what's gonna
pop out what is there anybody there and
I find you with my boots yeah okay hey
didn't need a whip out the girls just
then I'll put away for a rainy day
shut up I'm a man I'm just getting in
touch with my inner woman hahaha don't
ask don't look at me that way
ee loading screen hurry up this is
awkward uh
uh-uh me man
that lady not me okay we go oh thank you
oh I see him hey let's see ha ha push oh
my Tatas have a limited range
I cannot affect them from this distance
the gate to the casino is on the other
side of the pool I am done at that but
the way there is swarmed with monsters
and he define to scare the vampires away
in order to reach the Kabam fires since
what are these [ __ ] vampires why do
I need to scare them away why can't I
just kill Wow ok hi Boosh didn't see
that coming did ya oh yeah
now you're all oh I missed okay you're
not oh you're not okay I can't tell if
they're oiled or not are you stay Oh
what's this
get ready ah here's a cup oh yeah
amazing know how these [ __ ]
switching from aiming to non aiming is
really annoying so is that like a
permanent patch of oil I can use it for
as many as I want
look he did yeah man
he was persistent hey wanted me just
like everybody does but only a few can
have me okay tonight great magic show
yeah you made everyone die good job
elevator the elevator will take you to
the hall but it needs to be actuated
first um door needs external power to
open it bull honkey where's the external
power there's the external power
regulator the flux capacitor needs more
whatever powers a flux capacitor
alright so it's obviously not in here
it's up there man I run slow hard to run
with these jiggling all over the place
excuse me I knew the code why am I even
on this ship like woah is a purpose
I made like Explorer boots on a cruise
ship this is a water sprinkler with fuel
in it maybe I can use it to fight back
those bastards okay so I get it so how
do I use it you're not telling me what
button to press
i-i-i i don't know
glunk green assumed I could present Oh
what about this one but this seems to be
the energy control panel of the pool
room what it looks like it's broken damn
I can't fix it like this I need a few
tools I'm sure there should be what I
need in the hall shops and the warehouse
down below well I thought that was
something extra the staff elevators have
been activated did that say how did I do
that I'm just that good and I'm good
like I said I'm a strong independent
lady who don't need no man to fix no
elevators for me look at me I'm a
shining you where'd these come from ha
who did that who thumped who did that
who did that hello hello ha ha oh you
didn't see that uh how do i light you on
fire I don't know screwdriver aah
one of the things I need to fix
equipment dude little booth aha no one
can resist I'll just go over to pool
over here since I don't know how to use
whatever the hell they gave me come on
do your stupid leaps aah
Boosh oh there's Wow
burn oh come on why don't you burn there
you that's better better thank you for
turning straight to ash so I have a
screwdriver but I need more police I
think I need more how do I even sure how
long this game is
look I feel I really don't know I'm
utterly confused it's not bad I actually
kind of like it I mean the Buchanan's
are kind of wonky but ah
oh hi please thank you who's this
where's Eko where am i oh wait a minute
I'm over here I'm on the other side of
the oh okay oh I got it
aren't I just looping back to where I
was yeah I'm exactly where I was
huh oh okay everything is okay ah where
oh you're deaf boom Boosh yeah that's
right here Oh what that huh
huh go walk right dude up aw damn it you
went right over the fire that's not what
you're supposed to do gosh no don't jump
through the fire oh yeah Wham blinded by
the light sorry I'm pasty white my I
haven't gotten a tan as you can see I
use Explorer boots to look for casual
wear what do you think I wear to the
beach what a security alarm
oh no hi hi doctor yeah nah uh yeah
that's right
you think you could take me ah light on
fire what how did I die even fair it's
not even fair oh yeah you made a mistake
there okay so I am almost out of flares
I would think there we go you're all
done far no I'm just gonna run around in
a circle until you die ha both oh yeah
oh with dying wish granted yeah yeah
yeah I'm so pretty hey boys a pair of
hands doing there why are there a pair
of hands on the ground are those gloves
oh good okay I think is that good I got
all the items I need to restore the
energy of the swimming pool the energy
of the swimming pool
oh the energy of the swimming pool deck
okay I get it I get it
oh thank you you ported me right to here
well that's convenient
all right Tyra hello that should be
enough
listen no don't shut down
we're just shutting down now I only have
to wait that sound is bad might as well
just stay naked so that you don't how do
i I don't know I don't know how to use
the thing you gave me the number buttons
do not switch anything I'd uh I do not
know please be I can't I do not know how
to use the spray how do I use this Bry
oh ah I'm phoned I'm good your bra my
only defense is my incredible rack Pam
get away such a brush I only got one of
them lift you weren't looking guy miss
down um I don't know how to use the
stupid spray and I got it no I don't
want to leave I want to know the
controls haha right price um in a mode
that I got a fan that was reload I don't
know what I'm doing now I'm just doing
the cha-cha I'm on the crawling around
okay no no no no that's not it oh that's
not it either
oh that wow I wish that was it okay here
we go what's this use it to oil them I
would like that I'd like that very much
you Tommy after Oh are you telling me
that I have to nope that's not right
either
oh I don't know I'm I do not know I do
not know how would I go I uh I'm just
gonna stand here and I'm out press
buttons until somehow I figure out how
to oil you bastards up because you oh
when you guys get the oil oh you guys
are gonna enjoy it you guys are gonna
like it so much
oh man oil all over your buys yeah I
agree it's great feeling in the world
I took your job
no there's nothing I'm scrolling
wheeling I'm pressing every of ah how
did I do that how did I do that I'm
about to die spray them spray them ray
them
wasn't that nice you brought me right
back to here uh how can be for me what
that my life like okay you got oil now
you're gonna get oiled do it whether you
like it or not there we go
how did I do that did I presume not
wasn't Q system started I'm gonna figure
this out because I pressed every button
on the thing and then suddenly it
switched I don't know how because I
swear I've pressed every button multiple
times huh how did that how did that
happen how did that happen I don't know
I'd confuse okay so I'm just pressing
every button
no no et okay no that's the map that the
map oh it's the number keys when you're
in aiming mode ah
ah I'm a strong independent woman who
don't need no man and it's gonna kick
got ah of you a jaw chuck it down [ __ ]
god I don't even care anymore screw you
screw you I'm going this way
the music is far too dramatic oh good
you know you stand yeah wait there the
pool lights have gone off okay what does
that mean I must get out of here fast I
need to get the casino to get out of
here okay
alright alright then let's go to the
casino gamble our troubles away because
apparently things are going wrong here
it's okay as we have established I am
idiot I couldn't figure out simple
switch mechanic oh look there's lot of
them good I don't like that I like a
challenge
just as too many of those monsters need
to be very careful in silent when
passing through I know how do I know
that the security man I can take his
security card to open the staff do exit
door you can't burn them oh because he
has a card that's right what can I do to
clear the way ah if I remove the lamp
supports will fall on them and I'll be
able to go and pick up the security card
there is all one already taken out but
the other one isn't I need to go
upstairs and remove the support I don't
see what support you're talking about
but okay I'll believe you
oh there's a tutorial ha ha ha hose that
let me just light up this machinery here
so I can gamble
oh that ok
excuse me I just gotta go over this why
you don't see a thing
watch as I passed my boobs are you
kidding huh man they must be really
distracted if they didn't see that I
mean come on who wouldn't want to see
that nice send beams if I rose again no
okay well I guess we're all right then
hmm I guess they don't want a piece of
me who wouldn't want a piece of this
look at me how good I look at my
Explorer pants a damn I look good okay
how do I get around here without
alarming them don't see Ave there does
not seem to be a path there's something
blocking me here I gotta climb up for
this Eddy bitty hump a speaking of
anybody humps no never
now right go find Rob oh my god okay
alright nevermind I got got dirt oh wait
is this a port here or something hey I
can't see
not nothing here I don't see anything
where's this supposed support oh there
oh I see it I think I see it yeah I
think I see it okay so how do I get
around this is a dead end
this end is dead his dead his end
excuse me I'm uh now Jaime just sneaky
guru ah ha ha ha ha ha ha he sure it was
only about our time Bob off that's what
I get for [ __ ] around ah that's what
I get in case you didn't know so I'm
just gotta finish this game in one
playthrough cuz I don't want to make
this a multi-word I just want it like
get in and out cuz I didn't know what I
was getting into in the beginning and I
certainly don't know what I'm getting
into now I certainly don't know why I'm
doing anything that I chose to do the
choices that I have made I've led me to
this Aran point in my life maybe I
should oh maybe I should get a career
outside of deep jungle exploration hmm
maybe no my continued
and place safe did enough again decorate
oh god I gotta learn how to breathe
every once in a while yeah bras are so
constricting right right ladies right
yeah I know I five I'm right there with
you
don't ask doubler gimme don't look at me
like that it's perfectly normal
what I'm doing yeah okay all right tell
him here we go ah ooh are you so nice
ah actually I was kind of nice I mean
the graphics of this game aren't
tremendous but I mean compared to some
of the indie horror games at least one
this one has like you know completely
unique art okay completely unique art
and everything this actually seems like
it was made by a professional game
studio if only you know a while ago but
I mean it's it actually is exceptionally
well made for what it is which I assume
is an indie horror game indie survival
horror I want to know what I'm gonna
encounter in town er
encounter that supposed monster that I
saw before hey what the hell well that's
not normal oh no I have to be careful
careful is my middle name watch this
minute study the pattern huh Luigi shark
birthday uh I'll get me wait hang on
yeah then then and Dinoco how else goes
actually
ha meetcha dick ha ha
I'm so strong once we rip this down with
our bare hands ha all that Arctic
exploring really helped me out there I
remember when I had to move glaciers
with my bare pinky after my whole hand
was trapped under ice
I just cheap good now I can go back down
recover the security guard are the
flames gonna turn off magically No Oh
apparently not ah oh good
oh that don't hurt it don't hurt hey
don't hurt I thought they were instant
kill that didn't hurt at all hey let me
go get these over here and then I'll go
baby on my way
what is it over here anyway 10 flares
plus hey and I got a check just to be
thorough my my explore center tickling
my floor senses tingling odo a
mysterious chair standing here alone not
interesting at all good that's he
alright there was nothing there that was
a waste of my life so let's go back
why did they even make that I guess to
continue that you lay out of the balcony
I suppose to make it seem like it wasn't
just an incomplete ship don't know why
they're a giant holes ripped in it I
mean it's a disease but what was that
what was that
Oh oh hi are they old they're not oiled
are they they're not oil uh hi hey
buddies Hey
looking for a good time let's see okay
no sweat and uh no don't do that don't
do that spray the oil oil the ground and
then switch back and then light it on
fire
Oh Ernie oh that's just okay you why are
you you attack really strangely Oh what
the hell happen
where'd it go there we go light it light
it light it why aren't you letting on
fire you [ __ ] aren't you dying you
[ __ ] oh come on light it light it light
there we go okay now put this away and
just run in a circle jeez the combat
mechanics are not conducive to
appropriate fight-or-flight situations
the music is a little overly dramatic I
think okay and then it just cuts way
around okay oh there it was was over
there and thank you for the key card to
just appearing like that okay where's
the staff exit important doors okay
sounds good to me important doors here
we go on my way is anybody here is there
a final boss battle coming up I smell to
find a boss
okay here we go it's to York it's to
York it's to York I was used to flash
late it's too dark
the smells it's gas I can't use any kind
of fire here cause the whole area could
explode I'll have to reach the exit
using only the flash I should I should
better hurry I should better hurry
ah okay I got the only weapons I need
right here
yeah ah take the puppies out and all of
the my milkshake brings all the boys to
the yard
they're like it's better than yours
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] you hi I flashed you works
why aren't you blinded by the light ah
hi push oh yeah I know I know I know
all right here jay-z's how far is it
thing wow I can't my voice crack a
little bar that's it I'm so bad ah table
room oh yeah
you're welcome goodnight oh don't mind
me gasps all of the explosions islanding
things oh hello I'm no longer in control
now whose look at all the boys coming
after my milkshake
okay I still didn't know my story had
just begun haha wait no you said it just
begun and that was the end what hey
you're not making a lot of sense lady
but alright there you have it dark ocean
the game I still have no idea how it got
on my computer in the first place I
don't remember going to any website at
all but it was actually really well made
I mean the comment system was a little
clunky but for what it was I didn't pay
any money for it I don't think okay it
was just a free game that was voiced yo
voice well it was well designed a level
scheme chart the level design was you
know really well made in a lot of ways
and um the taxes were nice had a custom
animation to that you know a unique
combat system it just didn't work out
perfectly but you know it was nice I
don't remember there being any physics
in there but I don't wait I don't know
where I got it but I'm gonna try to look
it up as always I try to put things in
links to the content in the description
below so if it's not there that means I
couldn't find it so if it's not there
someone else please help me out and find
it for me and then send me an email with
the link so house X that was actually
pretty good I had fun I mean I was being
silly the entire time but I did have fun
while I was playing it so um yeah it was
a nice little surprise to open up my
game folder and be like oh what the hell
is it oh okay well I played it so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
the